[Music]
yeah you heard that right nicki minaj's
infant son just said hi perfectly on cue
consider us impressed well thank you the
adorable moment was captured on nikki's
instagram the proud mom and her husband
kenneth petty filmed themselves hanging
with their baby boy who seemingly spoke
his first word on camera
say me and mama laughed at that
[Music]
the cuteness doesn't end there nikki was
clearly in a generous mood sharing a few
more home videos with her little one
have fun
you look cute
that's it mama said say say mama i know
i'm a cute boy
and this one of the 11 month old whose
name has yet to be revealed charging
towards the camera
i'm very excited about that though nikki
has been pretty private about her
personal life she has shared glimpses
here and there of her baby boy here he
is in may attempting to take his first
steps
you ain't trying to do all of that today
you're um trying to do all of that today
everybody bothering you
you had it and here's nikki always on
point with her voice imagining her son's
response
um i had it leave me online already
please and everybody got time for all of
that
i always want to be great at anything i
do nikki has achieved countless
milestones as one of the most successful
and respected women in music but there's
no doubt her greatest achievement was
becoming a mom i do feel like a queen
the 38 year old rapper welcomed her son
in september 2020 and posted the first
images of him in january along with a
caption that read in part quote becoming
a mom is by far the most fulfilling job
i've ever taken on sending love to all
the superhero mothers out there
you